the show that I'm just winding up now uh
the work of the devil which which
contained two major revelations in the
second half one of which the most famous
one and what it's sort of about it was
the discovery that I was donor conceived
and um I learned through a DNA test that
I was actually conceived in a clinic in
central London run by a woman called
Mary Barton and her husband Beto Wiesner
and the husband bertolviesner was it
turns out supplying the vast majority of
the sperm that was getting women
pregnant over the course of about 22
years this has become there are other
cases of this coming out there's been
one come out this week in fact but at
the time and for several years this was
a standalone it's thought to a father
somewhere between 600 and a thousand
children so I have all these half
siblings I was curious uh to to touch on
uh your relationship with your father
and I'm curious about you talk about it
in the show a little bit the impact that
had because here you are you suddenly
realize this person you've called your
father and thought of as your father and
treated as your father uh isn't your
biological father and he was you know
what maybe this will be me revealing
publicly how weird my parents were but
they always asked me what how I would
feel if I'd found out I was adopted now
in my case there's zero chance of that
because they had me when my mother had
been 18 for four days right so I don't
think they were in the adoption market
so to speak at all it was a complete
accident and again wouldn't have
happened if people had thought about
childbirth as carefully as you suggest
they do no um but it is an interesting
question I think and the question that
most people would actually think about
in some way you know what happens if you
realize that your parents or one of your
parents isn't actually your parent yeah
it's interesting that your parents would
ask you that I mean mine obviously
steered me away
I mean I remember you did used to think
when I was I remember very specifically
having these thoughts I think maybe age
or nine but I can picture myself in bed
thinking I
think he's my dad and
and yet I cannot imagine a scenario that
would that would explain that because I
knew I wasn't adopted because my mother
had gone into a lot of detail about
exactly how painful and touch and go
labor had been you know I was in I think
an incubator for a couple of days and
she was desperately like sad that she
wasn't allowed to hold me and cuddle me
and she talks about that quite often and
we get Misty eye talking about it you
know and you wouldn't make that up you
know just to kind of give plausible
and so I knew she wouldn't have had an
affair I mean there was like zero chance
of that or anything weird like that and
obviously it never occurred to me that
such a transgressive scenario as as
artificial insemination would have been
used well why did you think that your
dad is not your dad is it just because
you're so different it's a really good
question I think at that age I can't
have been thinking it logically so I
think it must have been visceral and I
think what it might have been I I
sometimes think it might have been
um like pheromones or something like
that I used to be quite affectionate I
would sit on his lap sometimes when I
was little and watched TV you know and I
would I was very fond of him and he was
a you know lovely Big Bear to hug
but I kind of felt differently about his
smell and being than I did about my
mothers you know with whom I would kind
of absolutely you know
um Nestle up to like like a pup in a
basket you know whereas with him it was
more like an uncle and I do remember
also I had another Uncle we're a quite a
small family my mother's an only child
as well and my father has one half
sister his mother died very sadly before
he was one and um and his father
remarried and uh and they had Margaret
and so Margaret is supposed to be
related to me and it turns out isn't as
well my cousins her two daughters were
supposed to be related to me aren't
related to me and then there was Fred
her husband who was not supposed to be
related to me and I always instinctively
felt a really strong bond with Fred
because I because I think I'd I'd
mapping this out now but I think it was
because
I didn't sense that I that there was
something I was supposed to feel or
sense that I wasn't getting so I relaxed
about it do you know what I mean he was
just a man who was married into our
family and so I kind of instantly oh
we're we're like you you and I we're the
same you know but where that came from I
mean I just don't know
um and I don't want any of this I mean
my dad was really a great dad you know
he was a totally like a mensch
but you know it was weird I know my um
my one of my best friends Danny uh
Solomon who um I was at University with
and his dad uh Harry Solomon you really
do stick with you a lot don't you yeah
yeah so he used to come up to you or
down to South amplification and take us
out for dinner and Harry took us out for
dinner me and Danny at one time and um
I had this weird feeling like um this is
weird this feels like a dad
you know like uh this is how I you know
I I'm getting a little kind of bat
signal like a of uh
this could be and then when I met
Jonathan Wiesner who again is 78 I think
um who is the natural born son of
Bertolt Reasoner and Mary Barton and was
the kind of Rosetta Stone through which
we all went oh where it is
he's quite like Sahari Solomon and quite
like again I mean he's my brother but
but I actually feel like he's my father
so you you genuinely feel like kinship
with people to whom you're biologically
related to you perhaps hadn't met before
in yeah that is so interesting man I
mean the first time I went into that
room where they were all having lunch
the first big Gathering I was you know
it was they were the first there were 27
of them in there and they were the first
Blood relatives I had been in a room
with
ever wow basically putting aside my own
mother you know blood relatives of any
thing approaching my own tear you know
my own generation
I mean that's extraordinary isn't it at
the age of what 55 or something you know
it reminds me of something I was talking
to a friend of mine because obviously my
wife and I we left having children quite
late yeah so we'll probably you know who
knows how many will be able to have I'd
happily you know have a lot unlikely
biologically to happen and I was talking
to a friend of mine who has adopted
children
and he without being overt about it was
kind of he was saying it's it's not as
rosy a thing as you think now I'm not
saying that's always the case for people
but it's interesting that there is that
physic whatever physical or whatever it
is it's so fascinating to me but we we
went on this side track a little bit and
I asked you about the relationship with
your father and what changed for you
when you found out that actually you're
not by and it sounds like partly things
clicked into place for you yeah I mean I
suppose yes there's always a point you
you lose something I suppose
um we have moved into perhaps a slightly
more pragmatic recognition of the truth
and I know he felt hugely relieved when
um I went up and told my parents you
know and some people said you shouldn't
do that because it might be of a shock
to them they might have managed to
suppress that information apparently
there were some fathers who you always
attended the the clinic together but
there were some of them that were told
that their sperm will be mingled with
the donor sperm and it might just
encourage it Forward give it the full
propulsion when it got there it might be
theirs firm and got the woman pregnant
you know so there might be all kinds of
things that they've allowed themselves
to believe
but when I told them there was huge
relief definitely and
um and I think he had always just felt
you know that um it was a fairly trivial
thing you know and I certainly don't
want to like kind of like Shake him by
the repels and go no it's not surveilled
you know this is this is life itself you
know but my view has to be that you know
I have to recognize the truth of it and
there is a powerful Bond there but that
is absolutely of course not to see the
thing you I think the kind of the core
philosophical conundrum that you get to
through recognizing it and pondering on
it is there is no alternative it's not
like I could have been this or I could
have I would not exist they may have had
a child by some other means they might
have adopted or something but I wouldn't
exist there is only one set of
circumstances in which I exist and
that's it you know so there's no point
at all in thinking I wish you this or I
wish you that you know whatever or
recognize it it just I wouldn't be you
know yeah
foreign